I thought it was gonna get a little
weird during the commercial break here
as Holmes
ed Helmes of course the star actor from
the office and of course the hangover
he's got a new movie called tag that's
in theatres Friday June 15 I mentioned
at the end of last hour that mclovin
'he's wife went to Oberlin College in
Ohio and then we started to look and we
did some research and I'm saying when
Helms went to Oberlin College mm his
same age as your wife Oberlin College
not a big College and awesome would ever
ask my wife about Oberlin story she
always gets really vague I'm like yeah I
don't really remember what happened
that's vague words of parties and music
and I don't want to know all the details
edie can you confirm or deny knowing
McLovin 'he's wife Sarah I just saw a
picture and I do we do I do remember her
yes we were not close buddies but she
was in a friend group that I interacted
with and yeah
acquaintances yeah so you did not date
her good I'm glad we can I can relax the
rest of the interview
okay nothing tawdry go okay did you go
out maybe didn't date her but did you go
out with her I asked her out repeatedly
yeah you can leave now just one what
happens when you walk down the street
what do you hear from people a lot of
ridet did to do which is which is Andy's
catch phrase
ain't from the office if I'm in Las
Vegas I get a lot of headlocks people
trying to just jam Jagermeister into my
face and but yeah hottest place you've
been recognized oddest place gosh no
hottest incident event yeah well there
was one incident well yeah one incident
I was at a you know this isn't odd
because you this is very common actually
but a lot of times at baggage claim at
airports because because you're forced
to kind of stand there wait and if one
person recognizes you it kind of
causes a little bit can cause a little
bit of a scene and then more people
crowd around so that's um you get kind
of used to that after a while but one
recent one this woman said she saw me a
baggage claim and she's like oh my god I
just watched
I just binge watched all the office
episodes I love you so much can I give
you a hug would that be weird and I said
yeah yeah
yeah a meaning yeah that would be a
little weird but but she took it to me
yeah give me a hug and she just went in
for it real hard gave me a huge bear hug
and and she was right about that because
it was it was a nice hug action it's got
some good it was positive energy but do
you did you achieve fame more with
hangover or the office like was there
baring degree yeah that's a good
question and I I think in in with
regards to Fame I'm very lucky because
for a couple of reasons one is it was
very gradual for me because I actually
started out on The Daily Show and I was
on The Daily Show for four or five years
and that's kind of small cable comedy
fame just the occasional free bagel at
an airport or something and then and
then the office definitely kicked it up
a notch a big Network show and obviously
it was a very successful show but I
really there was nothing like The
Hangover I mean that just kicked it up
into high gear when did you know that it
was different your life was gonna be
different there were we so there was a
lot of buzz about the movie before it
came out and everyone was feeling very
confident and excited about the movie
but none of us in the movie were were
particularly big movie stars or anything
at the time so we didn't have super high
expectations then the movie came out and
we left almost immediately we flew to
Europe to do a junket over there and I
remember in London we were at a dinner
with the with the Warner Brothers
executives and the cast and everything
and they were and box office information
was kind of rolling in and it was
this it was clear that it was this
ridiculous phenomenon and that it was
breaking out as a juggernaut and I think
we all you know Zack and and Bradley and
I we all just sort of looked at each
other a little shell-shocked like what
are we in for what's gonna happen
what made you more nervous Mike Tyson or
the the tiger oh the tiger are you
kidding me
yeah I mean that was that was terrifying
yeah the tiger was especially the tiger
stuff that we shot at Mike Tyson's house
because it was at night and the it was
really windy and the tiger was in a cage
and and for some reason that it was like
the trees were all blowing around in the
wind and it was very jungle like and the
tiger was pacing back and forth in the
cage in a very predatory manner it was
daunting yeah we're talking to you what
ed Helmes the movie is tagged and just
reading up on this and even the guys who
were involved in it's based on a
real-life story and it comes out Friday
June 15th so you pick it up from there
explain to the audience the fascination
when you get this script when somebody
says hey I got a movie about tag yeah
and your reaction is ass and then all of
a sudden you start to explore it and you
realize that they've actually been
playing this game this is yeah based off
the truth yeah these real guys in
Spokane Washington they've been playing
since elementary school there now and
they're there now middle aged they're in
their 40s and 50s and and they've been
playing one and now one month out of the
year they still play this game of
tagging it's just open season they hunt
each other like wild animals so there's
10 guys involved in this 10 10 real guys
we kind of pared it down for for
narrative purposes to 5 in the movie but
but yeah there's 10 real guys and and
I'm not kidding I mean I I do I do think
that that without this being real
without it being grounded in reality in
this way you can't make this movie
because it's too dumb of a premise it's
too ridiculous but because it is real
then it be
comes really kind of exciting and fun
and and I I I read it knowing that you
know having just learned there was a
Wall Street Journal article that that
the script was based on about these guys
and I read that article and and I just
got intoxicated but I just wanted to be
I don't know I got a little kind of FOMO
or like you know it's like you like who
doesn't want their peer group to still
play tag that's kind of a for 30 years
what a great tradition but but how does
it work they all are in the same area no
no now they now they live all over the
country and they they will fly around
the country so somebody's it right now
somebody's at right now I think the
month they play is February in the movie
we play it in May or something so it's
only one month one month out of the year
yeah otherwise it would just be it would
take over there it'd be it'd be silly
otherwise make any sense okay so they
one month where it's tagged and they
just had their month in maze but no no
in February so now you gotta wait an
entire year yeah whoever is it for the
entire year is just sort of you know
piled on with humiliation and and
ridicule but I'm gonna guess disguises
yeah I mean they go to such great
lengths to tag each other they'll sneak
into buildings board meetings whatever
we're crazy disguises and and what's
really fun I mean we we took real real
tag adventures that they have actually
done and heightened them for the movie
and they and in the movie there are
these giant action set-pieces I mean
they're like it's like Mission
Impossible style set pieces but with
frumpy middle aged guy when they're
funeral involved do you guys recreate
yeah that's that's real that the so the
real guys one of them tagged his buddy
at his dad's funeral
and and we we recreate that in the movie
and actually it's a really poignant
moment because it's it makes them all
laugh at a time when they you know they
probably needed it and it demonstrates
how this game this ridiculous childish
game is actually just a mechanism to
keep their friendships intact and I
think as we get older and you know life
kind of takes on we get more
responsibilities it's hard to stay in
touch with childhood friends it takes
effort and and these guys have of this
kind of wonderful magical way of of
staying at each other's lives
the movie is tagged it's in theaters
this Friday June 15th be disturbingly
handsome Jon Hamm is in this movie yeah
very disturbed not even not fair not not
fair no he's handsome he's also damn
funny in the movie yeah he's just hate
that he's got too much I would hate him
but I just he's also a delight I love
that guy yeah we had a lot of fun I'll
tell you jeremy renner who's also in the
movie i wouldn't think he was a funny
guy yeah that's the one that's annoying
to me because he's like action star you
know Jason Bourne Mission Impossible
Hurt Locker Locker and he he is really
funny and that's not fair like that to
me is he's he's he's got too much going
for him weren't I was a guest on
Letterman when Ed was on Letterman we
said Danny was your final appearance on
Letterman maybe four or five years ago
you brought us down and add you know how
they let him and they had the green
rooms and it's pretty small up there
it's a pretty tight fit yeah yeah you
were the other guest when Dan was on and
but there was an incident in because
there was only one bathroom on that
floor yeah we felt bad before you what
one of our guys took down that bathroom
and and so I felt bad for you that I
think you might have been in the first
green well your room maybe you were gone
by then but we were like it was it was a
uncomfortable situation for us and then
we thought count if we ever run in what
will never
run into ed Helmes but if we do we
should at least apologize
so maybe I'm apologizing for something
that maybe you weren't even aware of oh
no I'm still scarred from that fritz or
anything you'd like to say to it a
candle or a match should be something in
the restroom you can't just have
Letterman had one bathroom I mean that
that building was weighted so we're
sorry about that
that's all right I was just in there
last night I did the Colbert show knows
now in The Ed Sullivan Theater and it's
gorgeous
how weird is it though that here's you
worked with Colbert yeah and and now
here he is hosting this and and I seem
like anything you know nothing had
changed but you know he's now in a more
higher profile position you are too and
you guys you know chewing it up yeah
it's it's um it's really cool I don't
know I I love to reconnect with with
people from it's a I guess you could say
that the Colbert show is like my tag
because it's kept Steven and I in each
other's lives and and buddies over many
many years you could be playing tag with
uh women from Oberlin sure knowledge
yeah all right the office episode you
stopped to watch whenever it's on you
stop to watch it there any any episode I
love there's not one where you go like
we love Kevin with the chili okay gray
one like I think dinner party is
probably the one of the all-time
greatest small TV yeah oh my gosh that
little plasma screen and just the
tension you can cut it with a knife it
was also one of the most fun episodes to
shoot a lot of lots of fond memories but
there's I if I happen to catch an
episode on TV I will sit and watch it
because we did so many that I that they
all run together in my memory I think
there are a hundred and sixty three
episodes something like that sounds
right yeah and but we did you could you
contribute to dialogue oh yeah
I mean as either through improv or as
you did improv yeah we improv especially
in the talking head segments those were
where we really I think just just really
played around and you know did tons of
takes some of the group scenes there'd
be great improv but it wasn't as improv
E as like you know some of the movies
that I've worked on but but they wanted
the feel is that you're just talking off
top of your head but yeah when you do
the talking head segment well hopefully
because that's where actors yes of
course you are trying to portray that
how hard was it to keep a straight face
with on the office yeah III was a
disaster of just breaking all the time
Stephen I mean Steve Carell just he just
slays me there's something in his eyes I
don't know I had to a lot of times I was
doing a scene with with Steve I would
have to look at his chin because I
couldn't look him in the eyes
it was just I would I would lose it
there's an episode where he plays Santa
and he's like you know being an office
Santa and I think Phyllis or Kevin is
sitting in his lap and he can't he's so
he's so awful about it because he's it's
uncomfortable for him and he's and he's
just being really rude and weird and
mean about it
and I had to duck behind a plant you can
see in the actual episode in the
background and by the way that was like
take 30 because I've been laughing in
every single take
oh yeah he's he's a genius there's
they're so much funny funny memories on
that yeah it was great were you in the
warehouse scene basketball Kevin I don't
think it was before you guys I don't
think yeah I think that was like season
2 and I joined at the top of season 3
because when Kevin takes Kevin to
disbarment
yeah I was a high school with with Brian
Baumgartner the actor who plays you're a
year behind him yeah
and he's a remarkable athlete have you
ever have you ever interviewed that yeah
we a week yeah we actually the how did
that come up that we called Kevin
anniversary on an anniversary of the
chilly drop yes so we we I mentioned on
the air and I had his number I said you
know will he come on and talk about he
said it was a one take yeah and then he
said he they had to replace the whole
carpet and he's just kind of rolling
around in this chilly and then he said
he went to Mastro's in Beverly Hills for
dinner that night and he said I think I
had chili in my ear canal he goes that
was a one-take with it when you know
he's just talking about this recipe and
how important it is and all of a sudden
I think it breaks me up every time I
start breaking that moment but it's yeah
he's he's actually a really great golfer
yeah plays a lot of I think you know
celebrity yeah Liberty events but but
competes I mean he's a really really
talented the movie is tagged it's in
theaters Friday June 15th Ed Helms who
may or may not have dated McLovin s wife
when they were collar hey no he may or
may not he's not sure that's a long time
ago but he's willing he sure I didn't
he's pretty sure he's clear but he's
pretty sure
now we're downgraded to pretty sure
before thank you for joining us in
appreciate and good luck with tank
that's Ed Helms for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
ass
[Music]